somebody else hoping for his own
fairytale ending the new bachelor Colton
under what but it seems the choice says
bachelor nation at odds no one can work
and I'm ready to find the love of my
life I'm ready to have a partner 26
years old a former pro football player
who loves dogs runs a charity and oh
yeah is serious about his virginity as
erst lzt the decision to cast Colton
came down to one thing
his story quote was too good to pass up
I am a virgin
really we're told Colton beat out two
other guys Jason and Blake also from
Becca season on The Bachelorette and
that ultimately producers felt Colton
was best to bring the drama and tears
last night on paradise we saw Colton
shed some man tears as he ended his
complicated relationship with GF he told
us he's ready to move on I have zero
regrets I have the same level of respect
and love 40th I always about today a Tia
congratulated Colton on Twitter and made
sure fans knew she wouldn't be competing
on his season and just a week ago Tia
told our lauren zima she has her doubts
about Colton as the bachelor how are you
able to be friends with him after all
those emotions are you over him at this
point it happened it didn't work and
it's okay do you think he's ready I
don't know that he's ready I know and
some of bachelor nation couldn't agree
more
this morning fans had a meltdown on
social media calling Colton too young
and mature and unable to commit but he
told us that is not the case and my
dog's great it's nice to come home to
sniper every night but I would love to
come home to my wife and have it have a
dinner have a glass of wine alright 23
is expected to start filming at the end
of this month the premiere is set for
January of next year
[Music]